hello
good evening can everyone hear me if you
can hear if someone would confirm in the
chat box that you can hear me yes all
right I haven't started yet because it's
still 2 minutes to the hour but and of
course I have muted everyone here
because otherwise we would hear you know
hundreds of voices all talking at the
same time so I'm the only one who can
speak and you can listen but you can
also put your comment in the chat box
and I will if you have questions I will
answer them once I finished my
presentation and I'll talk for about 15
or so minutes and then I want to hear
from you and in one minute from now I
will formally now here's a question how
to choose computer way to hear you I
don't know most of you can hear me if
you have put the link in to this needing
burner a website you should be able to
hear okay well we're just seconds away
from starting and all right I will begin
so I once again let me welcome everyone
to this webinar called three simple tips
or learning English I let me begin by
saying that first of all the recording
of this webinar will be emailed to all
participants and in fact to all people
who signed up it's possible that some
are not able to get into the webinar
because there is a limited number of
people who are able to actually
participate live but we will be sending
the recording with the slideshow to all
of you so
I am not a learner of English I am a
learner of other languages I have
learned to varying degrees of fluency 14
languages other than English
I have also interacted with people who
are learning English I have tried to
teach people who are learning English in
my business career I have either spoken
to people whose native language is not
English or I have spoken their language
in doing business so I am familiar with
the whole issue of learning languages
and communicating in languages other
than our own I think and I'm going to
try to speak very clearly so that
everyone should hopefully be able to
understand me I think people who are
learning English are lucky English is
probably the most studied language in
the world because it has for a variety
of reasons become the main language for
international communication so there's
lots of content out there there's lots
of material to use you know if if you
study a language that is you know if I
were to study Finnish or I don't know
you know Latvian or Vietnamese it's
harder to find interesting content but
English there's an abundance of material
and resources for learning English and
yet many people have problems with
English and can you see by the way can
all of you see this light show would
someone please comment No alright that's
a problem
share Mon it oh sorry there we go now
can you see all right so pardon me once
again welcome to this webinar which I
entitle three simple tips for learning
English people have problems with
English some
surprisingly simple things so while
English is a very important language it
has some real issues that make it
difficult the first problem is the
difference oh now it's having the oh yes
here and if you have questions you enter
them in the chat box or you can also
join the conversation on Twitter so now
let me move on one of the major problems
people have with English is in
pronunciation and the fact that English
is not necessarily written the way it's
pronounced so there's a disconnect
between enunciation and spelling much
more so than in any other language that
I have studied to some extent in French
to some extent in Russian to some extent
in German the writing system doesn't you
know surprises us a little bit but
nothing like in English and so this is a
problem so in other word and so a very
important tip in my opinion is not to
rely on the written language to tell you
how to pronounce something okay I hear
so many people for example who pronounce
the word bird heard word absurd
squirrels they pronounce them all
differently word becomes Ward because
there's an old air absurb becomes absurd
because there's a you there squirrel
becomes squid old because there's an i
there but in fact they are all
pronounced the same so it's very
important and it's a theme that I will
get back to that you identify each word
separately the word bird has got to be
identified with that sound but so does
the word word and absurd and squirrel so
you have to get used to separating the
way the word is written from how it's
pronounced
I mean there are many examples of this
plow though through Top Rock bow all of
these words are written the same way
ough and they're pronounced differently
you have to create a connection in your
mind between an individual word and how
it's pronounced you can't rely on how
the word is spelled a good example is my
father
my father who lived in Canada for 30 40
years who originally is from check us
was from Czechoslovakia and who spoke
English very well and yet he would
always say Nova Scotia there's a place
in Canada called Nova Scotia FC oti a TI
hey to him with Tia so Tia I almost had
the impression he resented the fact that
in English the spelling system was so
irrational and so he would resist the
fact that school Tia in fact was
pronounced Scotia so it is not
productive or useful to resent or resist
the irrational nature of English
spelling it's not going to change it's
part of the language when I learned
Chinese I had to learn 4000 individual
characters so you have to learn these
words individually and notice how they
are pronounced one other thing on
pronunciation is very important is
intonation you can get some of the
pronunciation a little bit wrong but
it's the general intonation of a
sentence it's correct people have no
trouble understanding it notice for
example in this sentence focus on
intonation notice that the UN focus is
not pronounced focused into the nation
again it's not intonation just
intonation rhythm very often the
syllable that is not stressed has no
sound
whereas in most languages they would go
focus on intonation or not in English so
it's very important in pronouncing
English to focus on the intonation so my
first simple tip is learn to focus on
what the word sounds like and not how
it's spelled and this is very easy to do
today because on the internet you can
use text-to-speech like I do a lot of my
studying on link and each little word I
can click on the text-to-speech icon and
hear how that particular word is
pronounced each word has to be dealt
with as an individual word you can't
rely on how it's spelled so that's my
first simple tip one other thing I'm
pronouncing don't you know there is an
expression the perfect is the enemy of
the good don't aspire to sound like a
native chances are you won't achieve
that you imitate the native
pronunciation as well as you can so that
you'll be easier to understand but don't
expect to be mistaken for native it's
not necessary in my years of doing
business I have dealt with people who
spoke excellent English and had obvious
accents whether it be Swiss or French or
Spanish or Japanese it didn't matter as
long as they were easy to understand so
that's my first tip with regard to
pronunciation and if you have questions
you can ask me later
on some people are saying that the
quality of the sound is not good I'm
sorry I can't do anything about that at
this point the next thing is grammar
rules grammar rules are difficult to
sometimes to understand and difficult to
remember to me the number one task in
learning a language is learning words
and phrases if you learn the free
if you get used to the phrases if you
see them and hear them when I read I
underlined phrases I underlined because
the phrases contains the grammar and I
can't possibly when I'm speaking
try to remember a grammar rule but if I
have read so much material and have
focused on phrases and notice them when
listening this is going to enable me to
produce those phrases correctly and make
no mistake you need a lot of words you
need a lot of words some people say with
very few words you can carry on most
conversations
it depends what your goal is however if
you want to have an adult conversation
with people you will need to learn a lot
of words words and phrases and so you
want to listen so much and paying
attention to words and phrases that we
start to hear these phrases in our mind
so when we go to speak naturally these
phrases come out so the process of
learning is not one of in my opinion of
an intellectual approach where you
understand a theory of the language very
often the theory of the grammar is not
difficult to understand I'll give you an
example one of the most common errors
that people have in English is the third
person singular of the present tense in
other words we say I go you go but we
say he goes or he does or she run and
people get that wrong all the time but
it's not a difficult concept because
there's only one form of the verb in the
present tense the changes in other
languages diverge change with every
person but not in English so it's very
easy and yet people still say he do he
go so it's not a matter of learning
somehow the theory of the grammar you
have to
notice and listen and read underlined if
you have trouble getting the third
person singular in the present tense
correctly every time you see it
underline it it sends a message to your
brain let's just start to notice it so
in this way because English is a
somewhat idiomatic language I mean all
languages are to a degree and I think
English is particularly so you have to
get used to it I should say that having
corrected you know writing and having
spoken having you know conducted lessons
in English but particularly in
correcting writing it's not grammar
mistakes that cause the problem for most
people it's the the use of words the
word order not using the appropriate
word in other words people haven't
exposed themselves to enough of the
language to develop the proper habit of
the language so one shouldn't focus on
specific rules of grammar but rather
through a lot of listening and reading
and noticing and underlying underlining
you want to develop these habits of
idiomatic English now one of the things
the third little tip is to work with
keywords keywords that like I do this
when I'm studying a language for example
if I'm you know studying a language
which has cases then I will work on
certain keywords which help me notice
how these cases work so we look at
English for example all languages have
nouns and and birds so if you're
learning English and in your own
language there are no articles then you
should be focusing on certain keywords
like though or even uh or an might
become a keyword because every time you
see the buff or off that article you
should look at what what phrases oh is
it a part of
similarly with with verbs maybe you want
to make
the third person singular he goes he
does maybe you want to make one of those
a key a key word for you in English do
become quite a key word because it's
used when we ask a question do you want
I want do you want or it's used as a
negative I don't want I don't go so that
do might be a key word for you you know
there are only certain concepts in every
language which all the languages that I
have studied basically address these
issues
what what kind where and so it can be
useful now granted this is something
that I do at link where I save certain
words and phrases because it generates
example and then I can see how these
words are used but somehow in speaking
another language you have to be able to
handle these basic concepts which to my
mind are the key words of a language
regardless of the language
what's more tenses which create problems
for people in English typically there
are trigger words which tell you which
tends to use so for example when if you
say when when I was eating when I was
you know sleeping suggests that the
continuous is used you know when you
phoned me I was eating breakfast so that
the when is often used with the
continuous form you know if we say every
day then it's the simple form every day
I eat so you have to find these yourself
but you will notice that very often
there are key words that tell you which
tense is going to be used
another thing you know just on the
subjective key word very often when
speaking especially to German speakers
who are learning English they will say
you know I have been living in
England since a long time but of course
we don't say that that's not how the
word Sint works in English we would say
I have been living in England for a long
time since 1995 but for a long time so
it's very important to to look at these
words again at least we can save them
and then we see lots of examples but you
can do this in other ways you can google
the word until or the word you know once
and see how these words see what they
trigger in the way of phrasing similarly
with expressing our feelings maybe
probably what if these are all very
important trigger words so often I hear
people say you know even I study hard I
don't improve but of course that's not
correct it's even though I study hard if
we look at the word even maybe using
Google or at link and look up examples
we'll see that even even me like even
with with a noun yeah but if you're
saying even if I do something even
though I do something you have to get
used to how these words are used now I'm
not saying that you shouldn't review
grammar I look at grammar regularly but
I don't rely on grammar as a way as a
solution grammar the review of the rules
is something I do awesome and
irregularly it helps me notice things
but first I have to experience the
language and I want us while I
experience the language I want to be
attentive to things I want to notice
certain words trigger words or key words
or phrases that help me so I guess in
conclusion I would say we have so many
more tools today that can help us learn
we shouldn't throw away the grammar book
but we should become independent of the
grammar book and try to learn using the
abundant content that we have on the
internet using use Google Translate for
example
if you want to find vocabulary for a
particular area write something in your
own language put it on the Google
Translate and see what comes up I go and
find podcasts in English as I do for the
languages that I'm learning use all
these different resources including the
grammar book but I think that
traditional if I look at I have at home
here
books on English grammar I mean I would
be very discouraged if I have to learn
English trying to follow all these rules
about when you use this would have I
would have been you know modal's and all
of this stuff I find it very complicated
for people like it fine but I think it's
not necessary I think there is a more
natural way of learning which involves a
lot of this thing in reading and paying
attention and focusing on certain
keywords and phrases in the language I
guess that's about it
phrasal verbs comes up a lot as a
concern again I think we should look at
each phrasal verb as a separate verb you
know put out put in put up with the word
put is there but the meaning is
different and so you have to feet each
one has a different word so I I want to
hear from you now I want to see anybody
who has any questions because I've
talked in very general term and so here
we have do we have any questions all
right okay now let me go to the top here
and see if we have in question first of
all we see at the bottom here Diego says
I always think in the rule the problem
was thinking was based on the rules is
that when you go to speak you're
thinking rules and from my experience if
you're trying to think rules
it's basically inhibits it inhibits you
from speaking because you're trying to
not only does it inhibit you from
speaking but you question yourself is
this the right time I am I spoken it
correctly most of the time if you rely
on your instincts if you have developed
a natural instinct
language you will end up speaking
correctly so so be less dependent on
remembering the rules and more dependent
on developing natural reflexes all right
what is the best way to memorize phrasal
verb
I don't memorize anything phrasal verbs
is an issue in English the other
languages that I have learned you know
have different issues but I find it very
difficult to memorize what I prefer to
do is to notice words as I'm reading and
I am confident that as I continue
listening and reading and if I if I
notice the words that give me trouble
and I underline them eventually
eventually I will start using his words
correctly if you look if you try to
memorize a list of phrasal verbs you're
gonna forget most of them alright so
here's one other factual upper
intermediate to really advanced level
you know at that point you just have to
read a lot listen a lot and speak a lot
you just have to do more and more of it
I tend to think in terms of listening
and reading is building up your
potential in the language and then
eventually you have to speak and you
have to speak a lot okay here's one I
can understand you how to teachers but I
can't understand films and native people
films are difficult I lived in Japan for
nine years I think it took me five years
to understand TV program and yet within
one or two years I was conducting
business in Japan with no difficulty so
if you're already not conversation with
someone and you understand the context
and you're communicating you know eye
contact with the person it's a lot
easier to understand watching a movie is
difficult so keep doing it and
eventually you'll get better now here
the problem is depart we don't have many
sites for conversation English that's
not true
there are lots of if you google
exchange you will find lots of potential
language partners also don't forget
don't expect that you can just talk your
way to fluency I still believe that the
bulk of your time should be spent on
listening and reading and improving your
comprehension ability if you have a
conversation with someone and don't
understand what they're saying you can't
have a very meaningful conversation so
anytime you have an opportunity to speak
fine but you should also work on your
comprehension ability there I understand
tongues but don't speak says the person
well then you have to speak more simply
and and if you don't have that
opportunity to speak don't worry about
it because when you are put into a
situation where you have to speak if you
understand well you will very quickly
improve Oh Pierce plan
someone asking me about my eye operation
I have my second eye operation Thursday
and both both eyes now I can see much
much better than what the case before
amazing you know lens replacement you're
in there for 15 minutes you listen to
the doctor and the nurses cutting up
your eyeball and you walk out of there
and within a day you can see very well
okay it is necessary to feel confident
says this person yes absolutely it's so
important confidence is so important and
that's why if you're trying to remember
rules that makes you less confident if
you just go for it make a mistake it
doesn't matter you the bulk of your
correction will be self-correcting you
will slowly if you're paying attention
if you're noticing you will slowly
improve the amount of correcting that
other people can do is limited just go
for it and speak and if you're
communicating successfully then just pat
yourself on the back don't worry
as I said perfection is the enemy of the
good
don't try to be perfect how important is
it to read daily newspaper absolutely I
mean one of my sources when I'm learning
languages I go to the online you know
the websites of these newspapers I
import the text into links because
there's words there that I don't
understand and then of course once I've
once I've saved words they're
highlighted in yellow I mean that's my
process but you can do it however you
want but reading newspapers is a great
source because if you are interested
again let me step back the assumption is
that you are interested in the something
so here's the question which ties into
that can I learn English only by reading
for pleasure
absolutely absolutely the more pleasure
you have in your learning the better off
the better you're going to learn the
more emotionally committed you are to
the process now how to find keywords
choose your own words that matter to you
you most of us are aware of what causes
difficulty for us whether it be you know
tenses or whatever until you have to you
have to find those keywords yourself the
more things you do yourself if you look
for content as of interest to you if you
look for words that you think are
important for you phrases that are
important for you keywords that are
important for you that is going to be
much more effective than something that
a teacher pushes at you while reading
would it be a good idea to read out loud
I think it's a good idea I don't do it I
have done it in the past I used to do it
with Mandarin where I'm trying I was
trying to get the tones one thing that
you could do is because intonation is so
important you could listen to a
paragraph or a sentence and then try to
imitate that intonation in a reading out
loud so but but most of my reading I
don't I don't read out loud
so again a question here from Salvador I
spent 88 percent of my time listening
and reading but what can we do apartment
speak with a partner yeah I mean that's
a problem ideally you find a language
partner where you have common you know
interests and as I say you google and
look for language exchange sites or find
people to talk to you know it's easier
for English I mean I for me to find
someone here in Vancouver who speaks
Ukrainian but if I see someone I don't
often see someone speaking Ukrainian but
I'll see people speaking Korean and so I
will definitely try to speak their just
reading without some tentative
confusions on pronunciation I personally
I like to have audio and text in other
words until I'm very far along in the
language I always like to listen and
read when I say that the words and trade
to start ringing in your brain you start
hearing them that comes from listening
listening is so important I think of my
study times 70% is listening but then I
want to make sure I read it because when
I listen I don't understand it
necessarily and so then I listen and
then I read it okay
now here's another person says every day
I listen but I don't feel I'm doing any
better well if you're not understanding
the conversation that well read it and
save the words you have to combine the
reading and listening we have to make a
connection between the spokes and the
sound that we hear and the word the the
written word is almost an image of the
word that you that you hear and it's
particularly important in English where
the pronunciation of the word as I
pointed out might be quite different
from how it's written and so you have to
associate the word rough ro ug H with
low you know rough is associated with up
sound though about the same way is
associated with it old sound so you have
to connect the audio
and and the the written okay now let's
see what is the best method to acquire
vocabulary in a foreign language well my
own view is lots of listening and
reading I keep stressing it lots of
listening and reading that's the basic
underlying principle at link we have
some functionality there that helps you
notice words and phrases you can save
them to a database use and review them
but most of the time it's spent
listening and reading and this builds up
your base from which you can develop the
writing and speaking skills you know is
it how much time you spend on alignment
before you switch to another do you wait
you'll reach a certain level you know
this depends but I think that three
months I mean we recently announced that
we're going to have another ninety day
challenge at length three months is a
minimum to make any kind of progress it
depends I guess on my interest but I
think a year you know a year is a good
period of time it depends how similar
the language is to a language you
already know obviously if you're going
to if you're going to go from from you
know Ukrainian to polish your Spanish to
Portuguese it's going to be faster but
if you're studying a language which is
completely different from a language
that from languages that you know year
two years is necessary someone asks if
this is available offline
yes everyone will be emailed a copy of
this of this now that the order of this
of this presentation
now let's see what are the questions
here is it worthwhile to go to a foreign
country to learn English okay yes
obviously learning any language it helps
to go to the country where the language
is spoken however I personally wouldn't
go to the leg to the country where the
language is spoken until I have a good
level in that language you can do so
much at home you know there's lots of
students who come to to Vancouver to
learn English I think maybe maybe 20% of
them really improved 80% of them spend a
lot of money and really don't achieve
very much recently on our format link we
had two people saying that they went
through intensive Spanish courses one in
Mexico and one in Spain and didn't
achieve very much my advice is to make
sure that you have very good
comprehensive you know comprehension
ability that you understand then when
you go to the country you can talk to
anybody because now you understand you
understand the radio you can understand
the newspaper you can talk to people but
to go as a beginner I don't think is all
that useful okay know how to learn and
improve two different languages at the
same time well you know why don't you is
if you are starting in the language I
would focus on one but you can certainly
focus on one and and sort of continue to
improve in another and you know it's a
bit of a trade off as we say on the one
hand the more you focus on one the
better but on the other hand if you have
children because the brain likes novelty
the brain likes novelty so sometimes
switching back and forth from language a
to language being back to language a can
actually help you because after a while
if you're pushing in on the one leg
the whole time the brain starts to lose
interest how did any advice on how to
develop constancy and you know this one
the most important thing is to try to do
things that you enjoy doing so so study
subjects that are of interest do things
that you that you enjoy doing that way
it doesn't matter discipline we're also
you know we're also going to have our
90-day challenge so you have a group
sort of pressure thing know how people
want how to keep motivation well you
have to that's your own problem really
is it effective way to learn English
word separately not in praises yes you
have to learn them separately and in
phrases so and and I learn them mostly
through the interesting context so on
I'm motivated to to read this lesson or
to listen to an audiobook and then I
really use the words in traces and
separately but you know some people say
well you just learned choices I don't
agree because to understand the phrase
you have to understand what the
individual words mean you have to become
more and more familiar with with each
individual word how it works how it
works with other words which words is
used together with so I think the answer
is you have to learn the boat what do I
think of SD meal I think it depends I
have I see meals for Russian Korean and
Romanian I thought the Russian one was
not bad the my big thing is how
interesting is the content I'm not that
interested in the grammatical
explanations I also don't like what I
don't like in XML is that you have a you
know whole translation of the text in
each case whereas I'm more interested in
you know individual word and then I like
to stay in the language that I'm
learning I kind of distracting to go to
distracting to go to a translation so it
depends I thought the the estimate for
Korean was very cool do you think that
recording ourselves with good way to
improve our speaking yes I do
absolutely I think that's a good thing
to do either recording yourself or even
doing a video speaking the language
because then when you listen to yourself
or watch yourself
you notice you notice where your
problems are and a big part of language
learning is noticing you have to develop
the ability to notice because most of
your correcting is going to be self
correction so by all means record
yourself this business about learning
English before going to sleep I mean I
have read that studying a language
before going to sleep is good for you I
will often read the lesson they in
Korean from our link you know at for the
iPad I'll have it by my bed and I'll
read maybe for half an hour before going
to sleep but I don't know I think what's
more important is the amount of time
that we are able to put into learning a
language whether we do it before going
to sleep or whether we do it some other
time
now let's see are usually reading with
Mac automatic audio but it's similar to
the Google Voice music even being a
computer the audio there personally I
use text-to-speech for individual words
and phrases if I'm going to listen to
you know five minutes of a language that
I'm learning I can't listen to
text-to-speech it's too unpleasant so I
would use the text-to-speech for
specific words and phrases I wouldn't
use it for a whole text and I stressed
again that I would say 70% of my
learning time
simply listening because you can listen
anytime anywhere I listen while roaming
in the car I listen while washing the
dishes it just enables you to put so
much you know create more time
I repeat language learning is about your
attitude towards the language about you
know the amount of time you put in and
noticing those are the three things so
by listening a lot you can add an hour a
day to your study time what do you think
about passive learning for example when
you work and focus on work is it also is
it worth it to listen while work
it depends what you're doing obviously I
cannot work say on the computer write
something and listen to you know
Ukrainian or Russian or Korean however
washing the dishes I don't need to think
of anything while washing the dishes so
if I'm working out I'll have something
in the background and I think that's
useful I find that kind of listening
call a path it's extremely useful I was
taught American English my son is
learning British here I find British
partner or maybe we're yeah I think that
the case of English you should learn to
understand British English American
English Australian English South African
English Indian English you should learn
to understand as many different forms of
the language as possible and and you
should learn as many words as possible
however you should decide which form of
the language you want to imitate and in
order to improve your pronunciation it's
very important to - if you're going to
imitate someone you have to like that
someone you know there's an expression
imitation is the highest form of
flattery
you have to like so you have to find a
voice that you like you have to find an
accent that you like and then you listen
to it over and over again and you
imitate it because you want to be like
that voice like that person so I take
one should listen to a variety of
different sources of English or Spanish
or
Portugese it doesn't matter whichever
language you're learning let's say in
the case of English make sure you can
understand people of different origins
but then when you say hey here's what I
want to sound like then you pick the
accent that you want to find and there
is no shortage of British English
content on the web one source would be
the Economist magazine which also puts
out audio I agree I understand you have
to pay for it but I would look for those
kind of sources
I believe that retelling is your
eternity was of course retelling it's a
good way but who are you retelling to
retelling to yourself retelling to
others I think there are many activities
that are very good it's a matter of our
interest our discipline the opportunity
we have to do those things I have not
been in the habit of retelling you know
if I read something if I understand 7080
percent I'm not happy and I go on to
something else and I think get into this
other question here from Wojtek the best
way to learn new words to my mind is to
expose yourself to more and more content
lots of content that's why I don't like
trying to master you know totally master
a hundred percent understand a limited
number
amount of content or to try to memorize
every word I find that that is not so
effective I prefer to go on and read
more and even if I only understand
seventy percent cover more and more
material because the important words
will appear over and over again until
you learn them once you forget you learn
them again you forget but because they
keep on appearance eventually eventually
you learn them now let's see other
questions here differences being
differences between British and American
English make a mess it's a reality you
know you can't
you can't resist the reality of the
language you just have to deal with it
there are differences but it's not such
a big difference
the words are largely the same okay what
else how to learn to move to different
languages just do it it's the same
except that you have less time to devote
to one language why can we watch the
video it will be available on YouTube
yes what do I think about online classes
and this to practice our English of
course anything you do is do it so
however it depends where the focus of
these classes is the main activity to me
is listening reading and speaking those
are the three things and writing if you
have the discipline to do it so if you
have online classes that focus on you
know speaking with you then that's a
good thing if the online class focuses
on some point of grammar I think the
benefit will be relatively limited no no
- Argentina solder said I can't hear
anything
mm-hmm okay
now do we have any particular questions
about English specifically problems that
you may have again I repeat that
everyone who signed up for getting a
copy of this video with the presentation
and recording now here's
my supposed to speak only to native
speakers no I think you if whenever you
have a chance to speak that's a good
thing but speaking to native speakers is
better I believe for a variety of
reasons to some extent when we speak to
non-native speakers it can be less
stressful because we think the
non-native speaker is not going to be as
critical as judgemental so we can kind
of you know expand a bit and play act
and pretend we're a native speaker and
he's also not a non-native speaker so we
feel more comfortable in a way but
ultimately because listening is so
important when you are speaking to a
native speaker what you are hearing is
is the the model that you want to study
so I think speaking with native speakers
I find it personally is more motivating
because this is this is the model this
is what I want to absorb it the way the
native speaker works if I if I want to
speak Korean with someone if I come
across an American it's these Korean
very well
I'm not tremendously motivated to have a
conversation with that person in fact if
two non-native speakers speak to each
other it's almost they're each trying to
show off how good they are whereas
speaking with a native speaker that's
the real test so there's nothing wrong
with speaking with non-native speakers
and in the case of English you probably
have more opportunity to speak to
non-native speakers than to native
speakers but ultimately the best test is
to speak to native speakers but you know
it depends what your opportunities are
why is speaking much more difficult than
understanding because you haven't spoken
enough at some point you have to speak
and you have to speak a lot and it will
be difficult at first I think English
has a lot of words with a huge amount of
meaning and I think that it's
particulate yeah but I'm finding the
same in all languages I find the same in
in Korean here again it's just a matter
of it's just more practice you
I find this myself in Korean which I've
been doing off and on for quite a while
now
a shiny begin to test that I'm making
that progress you just have to believe
that if you stay with the process you
continue your listening and reading
reviewing occasionally reviewing Graham
or occasionally reviewing words you're
going to get better so I think one of
the biggest problems with language
learning or language language learners
is they become negative towards
themselves and they are upset because
they forget they're upset because they
can't speak as well as they would like
or they can't speak as well as they do
in their native language that's the way
it is if you want to be totally
comfortable then speaking your native
language if you're going to learn a
foreign language if you're going to
learn English there are gonna be lots of
occasions when you are disappointed
because you didn't understand you
weren't able to say what you wanted to
say and you just have to stay with the
process now do you find duolingo a good
way to start from scratch with a
language I think so I think duolingo is
very easy you know it's it's somewhat
fun to do I think it's a good way to
start again it's a free resource there's
lots of free resources on the internet
so many more resources for language
learning than there used to be
ultimately now a duolingo you what is it
just google it and you'll see but
ultimately duolingo doesn't take you
very far and since to me I think it's a
great way to start and stay with it but
ultimately you have to get into reading
and listening to real authentic content
things that are of interest to you so
for you what does it mean to be slow in
English okay this question comes up all
the time
fluent means that you understand most
situations you can express yourself in
most situations even though you make
mistakes of grammar even though you have
an accent even though there are times
when you don't know the word it's still
fluent I have done business with people
from Germany Sweden Japan France who
were fluent in English conducted this is
in English and yet I could very easily
point out mistakes that they make and
their accent is is easily identifiable
watching your TV shows best way to
acquire the casual language sure
watching TV shows is good personally I
am not so you know I don't spend a lot
of time watching videos or movies or TV
shows because I prefer a more word rich
environment which means for me audio and
text so for example with Russian I
bought a lot of BD deeds particularly of
Soviet era movies that are that I love
to watch and but to me that is just
entertainment that stimulates me that
makes me keener to go and learn but I
don't use it as my main learning tool
okay
no so when to use even if and when he is
even though alright good question you
know if you ask me the question like
that I can't give you an answer I think
in most situations you can use both even
if but you would normally say even if
let's see you know even if I even if I
work hard you know I don't expect to do
well or even though I work hard you know
I can't really tell you I can't give you
a rule but even though
mmm I don't want to take the time to
take it through it's different there are
times when they're equivalent but I
can't give you a rule because evens
always closer - although in meaning and
even if it's sort of an extension of it
if if I work hard if I work hard I'll do
well even if I work hard I won't do well
so my solution of our mind my proposal
in all of this is to Google even if and
Google even though and see what you come
up with all right
or if you're if you're a user of link
just save those two terms and see the
different phrases that are provided as
sample phrases is it useful to think of
the language that you are learning
yes it's useful but it takes a while to
get to that stage and so don't be
surprised if your some things come up
naturally as you develop habits in the
language and some things you're having
to translate question here do you use
the use words that you learned recently
in your daily speech as a rule in order
to learn them better no I don't because
I don't plan my speaking activity
immediately after my my listening and
reading activity in fact the way that I
learn words is that I come across them
again and again again in my reading and
listening and then when I speak my main
concern is just to communicate and to
say what I have well you know try to get
my meaning across I'll use whatever word
I can remember bear in mind that that
your passive vocabulary is going to be
much larger than your active vocabulary
I mean that's even true for native
speakers but it's even more true for
non-native speakers so I need a large
passive vocabulary in order to
understand what people are saying
and then when I speak I make do with
whatever I can remember and try to get
my mini a truck when I'm speaking I will
forget the most basic words words that I
definitely know but when I'm speaking
I'm under pressure and I'll forget those
words and then after the conversation
I'll remember oh gee yeah I should have
remembered that was the word so I don't
have a deliberate policy of kind of use
recently learned words I just try to use
whatever I can I can manage to find it
you know you're under much more pressure
so yeah no I don't have it that's not
something that I do to deliver it they
try to do all right now any other
questions here we're nearing the end so
advise nation to watch series if you
want to tell - I kind of yeah I mean
sure as I say watching TV series is fun
it's not the most effective way how can
I practice they just juiced and send
text for an interview if you have an
interview on a particular subject or if
you want to sort of develop the
technical terminology and and as you say
the syntax very specific context
go and find articles on the internet on
that subject Google in English for that
by that subject matter find a bunch of
articles read them listen to them if you
can find podcasts on the subject but
particularly you read them again if
you're on link import them into link
save words and phrases that's the best
way I don't believe you know people talk
about you know business English or
academic English I'm not a great fan of
that I think 90% of the words are the
same and so there's a limited amount of
technical terminology plus you know the
kinds of words you need to introduce
your thought so if you have an interview
you might want to have a few good
phrases like in my opinion
on the other hand are you know my
experience has shown me that sort of
nice little phrases that can introduce
what you want to say because those kinds
of natural phrases create a very good
impression alright so what I would do is
this the if the interview is a job
interview I would make sure that I I
read a lot of material where the
technical terminology comes up and then
I would make sure that I have some nice
you know from my point of view in my
opinion yes that's a very interesting
word that can kind of introduce you to
the answer that you want to give in in
an interview I hope that makes sense I
listen the same new audio one week seven
day yeah it depends I don't do that I do
that at the beginning when I'm at the
very beginning I might listen to the
same audio five 10 15 times I might
listen do this you know we have that
link again we have like who is she which
is a basic lesson 26 chapters I might go
listen to one chapter one three four
times then two then three then four this
but and then I go back to one again and
but later on as I become America's
advanced beginner lower intermediate I
listen less awesome is using should in
unreality sentences showing your lewd
behavior no I don't understand the
question how much time you spend in less
than that link two hours is too much
time to spend a lesson with yeah I mean
it depends if it's a five-minute lesson
I'll probably spend I might going to
half an hour on it because it takes me
much longer
it says that the audio is five minutes
it'll take me 10 15 minutes to read
through it especially if there's lots of
new words then I listen to it so it's
hard to say it depends on my level in
the language now here's
Sabir even it is using conditional
sentences yes well even though is used
to express a fact true you yeah thank
you for that I think you're right
you see these are things that I use
naturally but julia has absolutely
nailed it even though it's not even
though you know it usually rains in
summer it didn't rain this you so he's
presenting a fact where you couldn't say
even if in that situation but there are
situations where the two are
interchangeable okay we've got three
minutes left
could you do a video focus on tip to
improve speaking to advanced learners
you know it can be it's the same
advanced learners have to do more
speaking have to do you know reading of
advanced material the process is largely
the same is that gradual getting used to
language any other questions here we are
two minutes away from ending this yes
you will get the audio is it useful to
listen to short tracks or long text like
so much in language money I think you
shouldn't vary it I think sometimes it's
nice to listen to a long track that
continues for 15-20 minutes it also
depends on your level in the language
but also sometimes it's it's useful to
listen to shorter material you get that
sense of achievement so do a meeting
teaching how to learn two languages at
the same time okay anyway I hope this is
useful to you one thing I should say we
would like to make a special offer to a
special offer to all of you if you would
and we will be sending this offer and it
will consist of a one-year subscription
to link for $99 and I will personally
follow you will be receiving a coupon
number and if you sign up I will
personally follow your activity on the
and you will be able to ask me questions
on the ask seed forum at mink and I will
follow your progress so if that's of
interest to you you'll be receiving that
in the mail okay okay thank you all
right well thank you all for
participating and just keep your
questions coming you can always email us
at the link or follow me or follow link
central on Twitter and send us your
questions there all right well thank you
very much for thanking me and I thank
you so bye for now